from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Cinnabon in the US and the UK
this is
[Music]
in the UK cinnabon's classic roles come
in four portion sizes as a single as a
two pack there's a four pack
and our largest size
a six pack in the US Cinnabon classic
rolls come in three sizes the single oh
my God
staying at the four pack for you and
let's be honest just you and then you
can get yourself a six pack this has
some weight to it
Cinnabon in the US also offers catering
sizes that you can't get in the UK that
means we can also get our classic
Cinnabon rolls in a nine pack catering
tray put that on the screen ah
that's 50 larger than UK's biggest pack
[Music]
but is there a difference in the size of
the rolls themselves we're going to wear
a classic Cinnabon in both countries to
find out
can get one bites in the UK but
unfortunately the store I went to didn't
have them this morning if you can get
them then they should come in a pack of
four in the US you can get van bites in
a pack of four
16 or the catering tray of 36. this is
nine times bigger than the UK's four
pack
four get a life UK Cinnabons also offer
mini bonds these come in three portion
sizes as a single as a six pack
or a larger size
as a 15 pack
use these as like a doorstop if they go
stale
over here our mini bonds come in
portions of one
nine
fifteen and of course we have a catering
tray of 20. what about the drinks in the
UK we can get hot drinks in two sizes as
a regular which is 12 fluid ounces or a
large which is 16 fluid ounces in the US
our hot beverages come in four sizes
small regular large and this big
catering bag
or does it
because they forgot those three the more
observant among you would have noticed
that the UK's large is only the regular
over here we can also get ice drinks in
the UK but they just come in the same
sizes as our hot drinks 12 and 16 ounces
the sizes change a little when you
choose the ice drinks in the US they got
the small and the regular and the
catering size again the more observant
of you would notice that there are some
beverages missing from this cup Joe must
have started drinking that earlier
had a major beverage spilling mishap
with a delivery here
more on that later the final things to
compare are the toppings and sources in
the UK you can get some additional
toppings like the cream cheese and the
pecans and they just come in the one
size
these little cups in the US we can get
extra frosting as a regular side of the
cream cheese frosting I mean a whole
pint
of the frosting
a side of pecans who cares let's weigh
the largest frosting side in each
country to find the difference
barely moved so this is eight of their
frostings soon to be seven
described as cream cheese ambient
Korean cheese that sounds like a a
really experimental music genre
it's pretty cool you probably wouldn't
have heard of it but yeah I listened to
mostly cream cheese ambient
here are all the Cinnabon items from the
UK that you won't find in the US here's
everything at a Cinnabon menu you will
not find in the UK to start off with we
have some bun varieties you actually
won't find in the US let's start down
here with choco buns so as far as I can
tell choco buns are pretty much just
their standard rolls maybe with like a
little bit of chocolate powder sprinkled
into the mix but then also they are
covered in chocolate sauce
yes
our next exclusive role is a Lotus
Biscoff Bond long time viewers of the
show will know that I don't really like
Lotus Biscoff I didn't realize how
passionately the crew felt about Lotus
Biscoff because I'm now taking heat for
this
um apparently it's because I don't like
coffee and they're really good with
coffee I just drink tea so maybe it's
wasted on me again look you do you it's
fine just not for me too sweet for me
and then finally because we're actually
shooting this on Valentine's Day we can
get a limited edition
Valentine's bun
all of our exclusive buns can also be
purchased in all three forms which is
the regular size the bond bites and the
mini bonds we actually don't have any
exclusive barns in the US we can only
get the classic and caramel pecan Vans
both of which are obviously available in
the UK but we do have some other
exclusives of showcase the first one the
churro swirls they forgot them
but here's what they look like
and I would love to have tried them now
we don't have cherry swirls but we do
have something called sinner chips which
are like small crunchy pieces of
cinnamon roll I'm not sure
if crunchy is what I want from my
cinnamon roll
they are crunchy they won't kill them
these aren't doing it for me they're
really kind of dry and a little bit
burned almost
so you kind of get that like acrid burn
taste
which cancels out pretty much any
benefits that you get from the cinnamon
sugar
we also have something called center of
the Roll which cinnabot has trademarked
in the US now here's what I'm assuming
this is by looking at it what it looks
like they just took Cinnabons and like
mash them up or like unravel them and
put them in a cup and this is smart
because the only thing I think keeping
everyone from getting a Cinnabon at the
mall is this kind of a pain in the butt
to eat and I think Cinnabon noticed this
and they responded with this like you're
right we'll just we'll just rip it up
put it in a cup and have at it
I don't want to mess with the classics
if you want to
sit on have a Cinnabon it's a food court
go for it but
if you're on the move just get one of
these oh yeah
okay are you kidding me with this this
is so great
oh yeah
oh I forgot
oh I forgot I'm shooting a video right
now this is the uh that was the regular
and this is the caramel pecan bun we
have a near equivalent here but we call
it roll on the go as far as I can tell
it's pretty much just the same thing
it's a small cup of I think just the
center pieces of cinnamon rolls I'll
just come in two flavors classic or
choco I do think my favorite part of a
cinnamon roll is the gooey little bit
this is pretty good
decent amount of frosting they could
maybe have given you slightly more
frosting because I think there's some
like drier bites in the middle but
it's pretty good in the US we also have
cookie band bites
these are chocolate chip cookies with
cinnamon rolls inside of I'm just
finding this out right now
chocolate chip cookies with cinnamon
rolls inside of them yo straight up when
I saw this I'm like who's getting
cookies at Cinnabon this has this cannot
have a cinnamon also oh my God you see
it and actually what I didn't even know
this existed you got that you got that
yeah
look at look what's inside of it oh my
God that's crazy the other thing was was
this Cookie's pregnant with a Cinnabon
a better an idea than execution
we also have cine sweeties which look
like mini Donuts that I'm assuming
our sin oh wait I think this has a
frosting on the side we've done these
for Taco Bell the Cinnabon Delights and
I'm pretty sure the spilled with some
sort of like cream cheese right what are
you talking
there's not
cream cheese in these the blanks the UK
Cinnabon website also advertises that
some of their branches will have Carvel
brand ice cream as an option but
unfortunately we didn't have that other
one we went to now we're on to the
sauces
beside of Oreo pieces
you're gonna tap your barn there it is
we also have the eight ounces of
frosting and we also have our clothes
this right here is you get a side of the
caramel frosting
that's also really good we only have the
one exclusive topping option here in the
UK and it's this one the Lotus Biscoff
crumb in the interest of furnace I'm
going to try it again
it's just fine
maybe with a coffee but
yeah
still not for me sorry guys
next up we got drinks ah finally I'm
dying of thirst we have coffee obviously
and you can also get yourself a hot
chocolate let's check out their hot
chocolate I mean it looks like hot
chocolate I love you see
wow actually not that good
skip that
we actually have a better range of hot
drinks in the UK including pretty much a
full range of espresso drinks including
an Americano a cappuccino a latte a
mocha and so on we can also get a tea
and a hot chocolate you can also
customize the hot drinks with a range of
syrups including cinnamon spice toasted
marshmallow salted caramel and more
although if you put any of those in a
cup of tea I will fight you in the US we
have way more cold drink options than
hats here are the following exclusive
code drink options first up cinnamon
roll cold brew iced coffee uh
another victim of the Uber driver
I'm falling apart pretty good too sweet
then we got the raspberry lemonade also
missing two inches ubified
I mean I don't want to give the guy a
bad rating but like look I've not sipped
any of these
oh my God this red lemon is great
shout out to Greta thurberg I'm going to
use the uh excuse my straw twice I care
about the environment
no more single-use plastic this is the
frozen raspberry lemonade
oh
powerful
this is really good bottle of milk
no thanks
and of course
Fountain drinks and in the most bummed
because out of all the drinks that
spilled
we have so many flavors to choose from
let's get those on the screen
but the one I specifically wanted was
this one was the pib extra
is perfectly fine it's a Dr Pepper
wannabe back in the 90s 97 98 or
whatever Mr Pibb changed his formula to
pib extra they're trying to get in a Dr
Pepper's market share it's so annoying
but the problem is is that there's no Mr
Pibb anymore
30 years
of no Mr pip is ridiculous I am using my
platform right now to talk to the
executives at pib extra or Mr Pibb
release the Mr Pibb recipe I'm begging
you it doesn't have any value for you
you're not making it so there's no value
right you're just sitting on the recipe
you're not even making it it's worthless
to you it
and I don't want you people watching
this happened last time people were
messaging me like oh yeah we got Mr Pibb
here at the Walmart it's like it's been
extra it's not Mr Pibb they're different
okay if anyone watching has cans of Mr
Pibb from the 90s connect with me I will
buy it off of you I'll pay for the
shipping that stays in the video or I
quit we have a few exclusive cold drinks
over here in the UK including an ice
latte a strawberry lemonade and a mango
lemonade I got the strawberry lemonade
today
pretty Pleasant quite refreshing also in
the UK is it true that you
th centered lemonade to be more like a
carbonated lemon beverage like Sprite
that's true Joe if you ask for a
lemonade in the UK expect something
that's carbonated and usually clear so
more like a Sprite although I will say
Cinnabon seems to be doing it kind of
the American way so maybe it approved
for that one now you can also get
something called a chilata in the US and
the UK however over here they come in
flavors of Oreo cookies and cream
strawberries and cream which I got and
the double chocolate mocha
that's just okay
don't bother in the UK children's come
in five flavors cinnamon roll strawberry
mango caramel latte and chocolate mocha
I got the cinnamon roll one today
actually looks pretty good
it also looked even more impressive when
the whipped cream was kind of in a nice
swirl
it's just like a again quite sweet but
pretty like luxurious cinnamony
milkshake
[Music]
you can always smell it before you see
it it's impossible to separate the scent
of Cinnabon from the mall and vice versa
it's like
a soundtrack to the memory but how it
smells so Cinnabon is like the smell
track to malls
does that make sense and that's by
Design Cinnabon purposely put their
locations away from food courts and
other food stalls so the Cinnabon odor
would waft and not interfere with any
other smells so if you're in the mall
you smell Cinnabon and only Cinnabon and
that's almost like
nose marketing I don't know how you
would describe it and it's really smart
right because when you smell it man you
smell it you're like there it is I gotta
have one so it's in about a meal a snack
a dessert I'm gonna go with snack
um I feel like one of those regular
Cinnabons I could just eat one of those
easily maybe one and a half I don't
really know my Cinnabon limit I just
kind of find out about these little guys
and I feel like I could easily not got
half this tray ah I don't think it
should be a meal because I could like do
some damage to your body as far as a
dessert
it seems weird to me to eat a full meal
and then get a Cinnabon like it just
kind of like exists on its own
so yeah it's weird to consider it a
snack but yeah you're definitely not
having it for lunch and you're
definitely not having it after a meal so
by default snack
in the UK a single Cinnabon classic roll
will cost you two pounds 99 Pence which
at the time of recording this was 3.65
in the U.S a single Cinnabon classic
roll will seven dollars and 19 cents
that makes this single U.S rule 97 more
expensive that is hilarious but does the
price change if you bulk buy a six pack
of classic rolls in the UK will cost you
10 pounds 49 which at the time of
recording was 12.80 so by spending three
and a half times the amount of money
you're getting six times the amount of
Cinnabon which is a pretty good deal in
the US a six pack of Cinnabon classic
rolls will cost you 24.99
so even when you are bulk buying it's 95
more expensive to buy in the US for that
same 500 percent increase in food we pay
247 more money it's not often on food
words that it's much cheaper in the UK
than it is in the US to buy fast food
how's that feel Jerry well it's Cinnabon
and I will pay whatever it takes this
stuff is amazing they could double the
price I'm still eating it
the UK Cinnabon website doesn't give a
full nutritional breakdown including
things like the fat and the sugar
content of Cinnabon however when we got
this sinner pack
I noticed that they actually have a full
breakdown on the box here we're given
the information for 100 grams worth of
classic Cinnabon rolls you might
remember from earlier when we weighed
one roll we found out that it was pretty
much exactly 200 grams so doubling those
numbers gives us the stats for a full
role in the UK here's everything that's
in a classic Cinnabon role in the UK
so that's almost 40 of your daily
recommended calories eighty percent of
your daily saturated fat and over 110 of
your daily sugar to put the calories
into context one of these rolls is like
eating three McDonald's hamburgers
here's everything in a classic cinnamon
roll in the US
you are reading that right 61 grams of
sugar and for some reason
1150 milligrams of sodium that puts us
slightly ahead of the UK in every single
category I mean look at that sodium that
is way higher for some reason that's
exactly 50 of your daily sodium in one
roll what about some other even more
unhealthy menu items the most calorific
role in the UK is the Lotus Biscoff roll
which clocks in at 1019 calories that's
a hefty increase on the standard roll as
well as being over half of your daily
caloric allowance or as we now used to
quantify things four McDonald's
hamburgers the least healthy rule in the
U.S is the caramel pecan bun which is
1090 calories this is also the most
calorific thing on the entire U.S menu
sort of a single caramel pecan Bond roll
is 1090 calories but according to
Cinnabon if you get them in a pack of
four or six the calories of each
individual roll increases to 1160
it is unclear why that is the case but
I'm going to go ahead and guess because
they dump way more frosting on it the
most colorific thing on the UK menu
actually isn't a row it's this a 16
ounce cinnamon roll chalata one of these
contains a whopping
1231 calories that means that one of
these large cinnamon roll chilatas
combined with one of our classic
cinnamon rolls in the UK would put you
pretty much exactly at your 2000 calorie
daily limit
[Music]
cinnamon does not disclose a full
ingredients list in the U.S only
allergens the website in the UK also
didn't contain ingredients information
but once again
the Box provided us with all of the
ingredients of a classic cinnamon roll
and it is a lot
but are there any ingredients which you
need to look out for the by myself is
pretty much fine despite the sheer
number of ingredients the things to
watch out for are actually found in the
frosting the frosting contains an
imitation vanilla extract which in turn
contains e1520 this is also known as
propylene glycol it's fairly common in
foods and in small doses is used as a
carrier for ingredients which aren't
soluble in water however it can be toxic
in large doses it's one of the main
ingredients in antifreeze as it lowers
the freezing point of water too much
pripling glycol could lead to internal
bleeding and kidney failure
the good news is that you're unlikely to
ever hit these levels from food just
don't go drinking antifreeze the lemon
extract in the frosting also contains
e102 sometimes known as yellow 5 or
tartrazine it's a somewhat controversial
yellow food dye it was parts of a panic
in the UK about food colorings causing
hyperactivity in children although
eventually it was showing that there was
limited evidence for this a 2015 study
also found that yellow number five can
damage your white blood cells which
makes you likely to develop tumors and
cancer
see us out dancing rats
a U.S Cinnabon weighs 222 grams 222 as
in the type of Diabetes this video is
going to give me number two baby